uh when we look at spax
this is exciting um i had one of my
company's desktop metals going out by us
back
i had rick phillip on the pod and i've
got four or five other companies that
you know i keep having spac promoters
contact me about and say hey do you
think com
or do you think robin hood or thumbtack
or whatever
i don't know like you got to talk to
them it's really not my place
but uh you know we have half the number
of publicly traded companies now my
friend chamath
is piling up the spacks uh my friend
mark pincus is piling up the spacks now
apparently
uh what impact will this have on our
business you and i
early stage investors um positively good
is it bad positive and negative
okay walk us through like most things in
life yes
um so let's understand a basic fact
which is
20 years ago successful companies the
best of the best went public in a six to
eight year time frame after being
founded
and they were raising money when they
were smaller
and younger and most of the appreciation
the gains that came
for the company came in the public
markets okay
so that was a net good for public
investors that was not necessarily a net
good
for venture capital now the good thing
for venture capital the good thing for
founders is we got liquidity earlier
and that's a positive right the bad
thing is we didn't capture the 10x so
look at uber
like your net worth is dramatically
increased because it stayed private for
longer if
you're forced to hold yeah and and you
may have chosen to be a public market
investor but
um but being private for longer
benefited people so what happened was
in the last 10 years the best companies
were staying
private 11 to 13 years or longer so what
happened was
money moved from the public markets into
the private markets and funded them on a
private basis so
capital availability meant they could
stay private they preferred to stay
private because they didn't want to have
to deal with the machinations of the
public market
and the vultures that are out there
scrutiny yeah the scrutiny and
whatnot um and so they stayed private
longer so people
like upfront ventures benefited because
our company stayed private and we were
able to raise growth vehicles
that could then invest in their private
rounds so all of the value capture
happened in the private market
but generally speaking i think it's a
healthy
outcome to get more companies public
because you know as they say whatever
sunshine cures all wounds or whatever uh
i don't know what the exact sunshine is
the best disinfectant there you go thank
you
um and and i believe that and so it will
sunlight and it will um lead to best
outcomes when
companies have more public scrutiny uh
of how they're operating and how the
companies are doing so i think generally
it's good i think
birds back coming or no listen we get up
there must be circling right the the
spak people must be pinging you
and saying will bird go spack i'd say
every late stage company we have is
getting circled so that's a better way
of saying how would you frame it for a
company like that would you want them to
go public would you want to stay private
and keep iterating so for me it's really
more a question of access to capital
right so if you need three to five
hundred million dollars
then you say to yourself is that more
available in the private markets or in
the public markets so in the last five
to eight years
it was only available in the private
markets i mean it was mostly available
in the private markets
now the the pendulum is swung and
there's a lot of money now in the spac
industry so a lot more companies
are now having the discussion about
whether they should use this as a
fundraising event
to solidify their market leadership
position yeah i mean for me i think
you know i have been thinking about how
long i'm having to hold some of these
positions and i would like to have
20 30 liquidity maybe
but that can be solved and is that is
being solved in the private market
slowly slowly i'm having it happen yeah
yeah
and then you i mean just this a
possibility of you know a great founder
being able to use that public
currency in a really intelligent way in
the way bezos did or google did or
facebook did
i mean they really used their equity in
those cases to buy
youtube instagram etc and the best
entrepreneurs will
because you have a premium if you do
well in the public markets and that
premium allows you to acquire
companies that don't have the premium
you know that's the case of google and
youtube
if ring was still private in this spac
era they would expect wouldn't they
probably yeah i don't see why not i mean
i would have
i would have loved that company to stay
private but i i don't fault jamie
because amazon is a great company and
he's partnered with a great company it
worked out for tony shea you know it's
one thing that
bezos really gets which i think the
google team learned later which was
just leave them independent if it's
working don't break it
like don't you don't need to break a
high-functioning
founder and culture at whether it's
zappos or
youtube or whatever it is just let it
sit over there and operate
totally agree um so acquire companies
that are already great at running
themselves